I don't believe there's such a thing as
free will in the sense of a ghost in the
machine a spirit or soul that somehow
leads the the tv-screen of the senses
and pushes buttons and pulls levers of
behavior there's no sense that we can
make of that I think we are our behavior
is the product of physical processes in
the brain on the other hand when you
have a brain that consists of 100
billion neurons connected by a hundred
trillion synapses there is a vast amount
of complexity that means that human
choices will not be predictable in any
simple way from the stimuli that if I
finished on it beforehand we also know
that that brain is set up so that there
are at least two kinds of behavior
there's what happens when I shine a
light in your eye and your your iris
contracts or I hit your knee with a
hammer and your your your leg jerks
upward we also know that there's a part
of the brain that does things like
choose what to have for dinner or
whether order chocolate or vanilla ice
cream how to move the next check chess
piece whether to pick up the paper or
put it down that is very different from
your iris closing when I shine a light
in your log your eye does that second
kind of behavior one that engages vast
amounts of the brain particularly the
frontal lobes that incorporates an
enormous amount of information in the
causation of the behavior that has some
mental model of the world that can
predict the consequences of possible
behavior and select them on the basis of
those consequences all of those those
things carve out the realm of behavior
that we call free will which it is
useful to distinguish from brute
involuntary reflexes but which doesn't
necessarily have to involve some
mysterious soul
you